début cette pandémie on croyait que la
propagation de la crise faisait
uniquement par les gouttelettes
l'exporter en toussant ou en éternuant
mais on sait maintenant et ça se
confirme de plus en plus que ce sont par
des aérosols ont joint une sommité en la
matière lydia bourguiba professeur
associé au prestigieux m a été de beauce
tombons soir alain boureau iba
bonsoir alors aérosols et au micro on a
l'impression que étant donné quand on
garde la transmissibilité de virus
maintenant avec au micro que c'est
devenu un cocktail explosif
est ce que c'est le cas selon vous
mais en fait la transmission par la voie
aérienne donc par l'air était là depuis
le début mais c'est vrai qu'avec au
micron il ya des parts propriétés qui
sont très effective pour 1 pour
atteindre
entre une très très rapide transmission
dans la population à l'intérieur et même
à des cas à l'extérieur parce que au
micron se transmet très rapidement et
vous même vous aviez déjà modéliser la
transmission par aérosol en 2010 avec le
strass et il semble qu'on a mis beaucoup
de temps à comprendre le rôle des
aérosols dans cette pandémie et ça c'est
une source de déception pour vous
pourquoi
mais en fait la recherche sur la
transmission des maladies par que vous
avez dit les grosses gouttes ou août let
versus aérosols en fait cette dichotomie
qui est en place finalement est basé sur
da de la science qui date du début du
siècle dernier 1930 est en fait une
série d'études et en entre autres celles
que nous avons menées en 2010 et ans
plus tard qui ont clairement montré que
ce genre de classification en deux
routes
gouttes faire sucer aérosols ne tient
pas la route même pour d'autres maladies
et il aurait fallu déjà un mettre à jour
les codes et les réglementations
sanitaires bien avant cette pandémie
pour pouvoir être plus flexible et
pouvoir incorporer la méthode de creep
caution mais aussi la cie sur comment
finalement on exhale et aimé des coupes
d'une de taille qui sont continues entre
100 microns et petite tailles très
facilement et que beaucoup de choses qui
sont basés sur cette notion de grosses
gouttes versus petit ne tiennent pas en
réalité la route en même temps il ya eu
pendant des mois un débat entre
scientifiques du joueur appelé à la
reconnaissance du rôle des aérosols
d'autres zones on n'a pas encore la
preuve absolue vous mentionnez le
principe de précaution ici au canada
dans plusieurs provinces australes
retour à l'école demain c'est déjà fait
dans quelques provinces mais il reste
que le retour à l'école en inquiète
plusieurs parce que il n'ya pas
nécessairement la bonne ventilation il
n'ya pas nécessairement les codes les
balises dont vous avez parlé vous avez
déjà modéliser la manière dont se
transmet peut-être le virus à
l'intérieur d'une classe avec des
recommandations si vous voulez on va
regarder cette courte vidéo pendant que
je vous pose la question on voit une
classe on voit un point rouge au début
près de la porte d'entrée envoie un
autre point rouge près de la fenêtre et
on voit le courant d'air qui se transmet
quel est le risque ici s'il y en a un
pour les personnes qui sont assises au
point rouge au début fois de la porte et
près de la fenêtre
oui donc là c'était une illustration en
fait basé sur des principes de dynamique
des fluides finalement montre que si on
ne porte pas de masque qui et empêche la
propagation donc ce petit nuage rouge
qui finalement ce propos c'est assez
loin là parce que la source ne n'a pas
de masque au bout d'un certain temps ça
se propage partout dans la dans la salle
si on veut augmenter la ventilation il
faut le faire absolument mais il faut
tenir compte de certains principes de
base qui sont que si on place les
individus à la proche d'une de la sortie
de l'air ces individus vont être exposés
de manière cumulative à l'addition de
tous les bateaux jeunes qui sont dans
l'air puisque ils auront finalement
qu'une ils sont et seront point de
sortie et de manière similaire si on a
un point d'entrée qui est trop localiser
et mal finalement e place et on
retrouvera avec si on a un un des
individus qui est malade juste en face
de points de source d'air frais on va
avoir une distribution très efficace des
virus de cette personne est en quelque
sorte en étant la zone 2 de respiration
sur tout sur tout ce qui est à l'arrière
de cette personne qui est en amont la
ouvert fripes entre est donc en fait il
y à certains principes de base quand on
veut augmenter la ventilation en classe
à qu'il faut auquel il faut tenir compte
si ce n'est pas fait de manière
mécanique au point de vue de
l'infrastructure mais plutôt avec par
exemple des purificateurs terre et pas
ou des fenêtres tout simplement qu'il ya
la ventilation naturelle mais
relativement d'abord oui bah merci
d'avoir parlé de votre expertise avec
nous ce soir bonsoir